[Musique]
voir
willy petite fille
[Musique]
derrière lesquelles
vous en saurez combien
onze espèces blue est la dernière du
genre vous ne pourrez jamais la capture
et vous savez peut-être qui pourrait
nous aider
une mission de sauvetage qu'est ce qu'on
risque un boulot qui me connaissent ils
ont avec moi tu sais que tu peux pas
rester ici
rappelez-vous sommes tout de suite il
m'a menti
l'homme qui a prouvé que les raptor
peuvent obéir vous ne vous êtes jamais
demandé combien de millions vaudrait un
prédateur dressé ils vont les vendre
table où ils ont d'autres projets pour
elle c'est la plus dangereuse des
caméras existent je propose qu'on arrête
ce délire
[Musique]
et bah ouais tu pense comme moi
on a libéré la puissance génétique on ne
peut plus faire marche arrière
l'eau
si je reviens pas
n'oublie pas que c'est toi qui m'a
demandé de venir ici je vais m'en sortir
ces créatures étaient là bien avant et
si on n'y prend pas garde ils seront
encore là bien après bienvenue à
jurassic world
[Musique]